[Music]
this year's Victoria's Secret Fashion
Show it's still a couple of months away
but the search for new angels has begun
so what exactly is the criteria to
making it as a heavenly creature we were
invited inside the casting process to
find out my biggest piece of advice to
an upcoming model would be to not be
afraid to be yourself
shriyak
an amazing personality a good sense of
humor veteran angels Martha hunt and
Jasmine hooks telling us the must-do
rules of winging it there was no lack of
confidence inside the makeshift casting
catwalk making sure your skin is on
fleek nails on sweet but there are rules
models have to wear a little to no
makeup all the ladies have to wear
identical black lingerie and hold steady
and sky-high stilettos this is the last
round of callbacks before November's
show and it's the same process we saw
Gigi Hadid go through in 2015
no word yet of GG sister Bella or
Kendall Jenner
are returning again this year but et has
confirmed Adriana Lima and Alessandra
Ambrosio will
also hoping to come back models alone
who went a little robe dancing with
Bruno Mars last year dancing together a
little of that okay oh my god afterward
those two things myself that could have
ended very badly the heels were like
this high
[Music]